only on cbs mornings we're joined by
uber ceo that's tara kasrashahi uber
says demand is bouncing back from this
pandemic with the number of rides up 18
percent in the first three months of
this year compared to the same quarter
in 2021. now the company is rolling out
a number of new and i have to say very
cool features from robotic food delivery
services services to rides and electric
vehicles and even party buses that's
right
dara kasra hashi dera kasrashahi i
actually know his name good morning to
you dar it's very good to see you and to
have you back on cbs mornings so good
morning good to see you
you'll be glad to know i took an uber
the other day i got in the car the
driver had on a mask and i said do you
want me to put on my mask he says no you
don't have to and i said okay so i
didn't but then i sat there and i
questioned myself because the new policy
says neither the drivers or the
passengers have to wear a mask
and i i know that that's okay but what
went into your thinking on that because
it still doesn't feel quite right to me
but i did ride in the car with no mass
the other day because i figure i'm vax
and boosted what's the thinking that
went into the decision
well the thinking is that we're really
going to follow cdc guidelines you know
we're a company uh made up of humans who
make judgments every day
uh and we don't want to necessarily be
making up under our own rules we want to
follow the cdc and the health guidelines
that that are out there
uh and allow individuals like you to
make your choice your own choice uh
feeling safe and you know the driver
obviously felt safe as well and we've
let our drivers and also riders know
that if for some reason you're
uncomfortable because of masking one way
or the other you can cancel a ride no
charge to you uh and hopefully we'll
navigate this kind of funny uh and odd
period this transitionary period
together yeah it is an odd period i'm
very interested in uber charter because
it certainly sounds better than six
drunk drunk friends packing into the
back of the honda civic on a saturday
night good times tony good times tell me
how this is going to work
well we're actually now just wiring off
uh all of the charter buses uh in in the
world hopefully but we're starting with
with uber charter you can get on the
uber app you can essentially say exactly
what you need how many passengers when
where etcetera and we'll give you the
upfront fare all of the information and
make sure that that charter gets you in
time to uh go have a good time
yeah i like it yeah that's convenient
after a long night getting that bill at
the end is quite surprising yeah
especially if you're tipsy um dar yeah i
want to know about some other services
i'm hearing about uh food delivery using
robots that is going to be launched and
testing in la
yeah absolutely so uber eats is
one of our fastest growing parts of our
business uber's all about go anywhere
and get anything
and part of getting anything is to get
you anything in every single possible
way we've obviously been been leaning in
to technology we want to be the best
tech companies in delivery and we're
working with serve robotics uh and a
couple of other players but serve in la
and this is happening right now on the
streets you know sometimes you'll get a
courier and they're terrific in terms of
delivering your food but sometimes
you'll get these little cute robots you
can put in a code and
essentially you can get your food and
it's a delightful experience
a friend of mine also known as our
executive producer said well you know
what uber's trying to do they're trying
to do one-stop travel
be a one-stop travel shop for instance
book your flights book your hotels
transportation to and from the airport
does shawna have it right are you trying
to be a one-stop travel shop
well we're certainly trying to be one
stop for you in terms of this summer
travel season right travel is coming
back in a big way i think people have
been
sitting around home for too long uh and
they want to get out there and one of
the really interesting products that
we've now built is uber travel where
essentially you can automatically
download all of your travel information
from gmail into uber and then you can
use that information to book uber
reserve the great thing about uber
reserve is driver comes early you can
rest assured that you're going to make
it to the flight on time etc and to top
it off we'll give you 10 off to make
that travel just a little bit more
forward
hey dara cnbc obtained a copy of a memo
you sent to employees in which you
talked about making hiring a privilege
it sounded like you're going to roll
back spending within the company i'm
curious what does that mean for people
who work at uber and what will it mean
for people who use uber
well i don't think it'll make any change
to the service at all you know we are
entering an incredibly uncertain time uh
fortunately for us our business is
growing at rapid rates uh gross bookings
were growing 39 on a year-on-year basis
this last quarter which is terrific but
with all the uncertainty going on in the
world etc we want to make sure that we
grow the right way and we're going to be
careful in terms of the investments that
we make so that all the investment can
go into all of the new cool products
that you've seen going forward but for
uber employees we continue to grow we
continue to build uh and we'll be
continuing to hire as well but carefully
in this tough environment
well they don't rate rooms anymore dara
but if they did you would get a 10. i
liked your background
very nice aesthetic whoever's doing rich
mahogany in the background yeah yeah
thank you very much